- I think about this Classic,
giving back to the community
and, you know, this deep
love of Black people,
I can't help but think about Killmonger.
- Mmhmm.
- And after "Black Panther" came out,
I swear I had this debate
for, like, three months.
Obviously there's no definitive
answer. Opinion is opinion.
But is Killmonger a villain?
- No.
- Please tell me why. I agree.
I think, like, he's an antagonist.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But I don't know if
he's, like, a bad person.
What is your take on it?
- My take on Erik— - And I'm also so right.
I'm so happy that I can
say we agree on this.
No one agreed with me, OK?
- Yeah.
- Please continue.
You know that feeling when you're like—
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "I'm one up on you." Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How you gonna argue with Killmonger?!
All right, tell me—
- That's a good one. That's a good one.
- Gimme your take.
- No, I think, I think he was a necessary
part of the conversation.
- Yes.
- You know, I think, you know,
he cared about his people just as much as,
you know, T'Challa.
He just had a different way of
going about getting it done.
- Yeah.
- I think he was a historian that studied
history, you know? The
history of, you know,
government and oppression.
And, you know, Erik's a really smart guy,
you know what I'm saying?
MIT graduate. The guy is
like—he's very intelligent.
And he saw that there
was only really one way
to change things, you know?
So he went about that, and I
don't think his argument was
completely wrong.
I don't think T'Challa's
argument was completely wrong.
I think it was a necessary conversation
that needed to be had. But, you know,
it's a movie also.
So you gotta, you know—
- And that conversation makes it good, right?
- I'm willing to take life.
You know what I'm saying?
To do whatever it takes, you know,
and this is what I've been taught.
This is what I've been
shown that works, you know?
So you can not like it,
but there's this other version
of trying to get change done.
And it's kind of taken a
little too long for me.
I ain't got that time, you know?
And I, yeah, I guess, but
I'm doing it like this.
- Yeah. I love it.